good evening I'm Stuart brand from long
now foundation and I'm curious since
this is now our usual venue or our usual
speaker how many here have not been to a
long now talked like this before
good that's we like that so what's a
novelist doing giving a long now talk
this particular novel focuses I think on
three things that we'll talk about and
the novel clearly talks about machines
like me that a bear's relation to
counterfactual history which our speaker
is taken on as something new for him
this breaks a lot about artificial
intelligence and how its embodiment in
our midst might play out and as in many
of our speakers books there's an ethical
morality depth to it raises questions
not necessarily all answered that is
clearly the kind of thing that thinking
long-term deals with profoundly we'll
start with our speaker alone for a few
minutes just sort of orient you to his
world the world of the novel and then I
will come and join him shortly so please
welcome Ian McEwan
[Applause]
thank you
Stewart and I thought we'd start the
evening with a reading but don't worry
it's gonna be very short and I just have
to tell you what a thrill it is to be
here in San Francisco in the long now
camp with such an extraordinary large
audience novelists are not used to these
kind of things
so here's the first page or two of this
novel it was a religious yearning
granted hope it was the holy grail of
science our ambitions ran high and low
for a creation myth made real for a
monstrous act of self-love as soon as it
was feasible we had no choice but to
follow our desires and hang the
consequences in loftiest terms we aim to
escape our mortality confront or even
replace the Godhead with a perfect self
more practically we intended to devise
an improved more modern version of
ourselves and exult in the joy of
invention the thrill of mastery in the
autumn of the 20th century it came about
at last the first step towards the
fulfillment of an ancient dream the
beginning of the long lesson we would
teach ourselves that however complicated
we were however faulty and difficult to
describe and even our simplest actions
and modes of being we could be imitated
and bettered and I was there as a young
man an early and eager adopter in that
chilly dawn but artificial humans were a
cliche long before they arrived so when
they did they seemed to some a
disappointment the imagination fleeted
in history than technological advance
had already rehearsed this future in
books then films and TV dramas as if
human actors walking with a certain
glazed look and phony head movements and
some stiffness in the lower back could
prepare us for life
our cousins from the future I was among
the optimists
blessed by unexpected funds following my
mother's death and the sale of the
family home which turned out to be on a
valuable development site the first
truly viable manufactured human with
plausible intelligence and looks
believable motion and shifts of
expression went on sale the week before
the falklands task force set off on it's
hopeless mission adam cost eighty six
thousand pounds i brought him home in a
hired van to my unpleasant flat in North
Clapham I'd made a reckless decision but
I was encouraged by reports that Sir
Alan Turing war hero and presiding
genius of the digital age had taken
delivery of the same model he probably
wanted have his lab take it apart to
examine its workings fully twelve of
this first edition were called Adam and
thirteen were called Eve corny everyone
agreed but commercial notions of
biological race being scientifically
discredited the 25 were designed to
cover a range of ethnicities there were
rumors then complaints that the Arab
could not be a told apart from the Jew
random programming as well as life
experience would grant to all complete
latitude in sexual preference by the end
of the first week all the Eve's
sold out at a careless glance I might
have taken my Adam for a Turk or a Greek
he weighed 170 pounds
so he had to ask my upstairs neighbor
Miranda to help me carry him in from the
street on the disposable stretcher that
came with the purchase
Thanks
I was in Manhattan some years back with
an American friend somewhere in Midtown
and I saw a very long line of people
many of them with sleeping bags I've
been there all night and I thought they
were waiting for maybe a ticket for some
rock show rock performance and I asked
my friend what it was and he said
they're queuing up for an iPhone 4 and
it's worth bearing in mind that all
technological marvels if they're
successful simply become everyday
matters for us and we live of course in
a world of biological Marvel's which are
commonplace like the little weed that
grows between the crack in the pavement
under your feet is performing acts of
photosynthesis that lie well beyond the
capacities of any in every lab in the
world so if one day we have a fully
plausible highly intelligent being among
us we not only will face extraordinary I
think moral ethical problems with this
but will also begin I'm almost certain
to take it for granted and really this
novel is an encounter a close encounter
I wanted to get a close encounter with
what it would be like to have a machine
that seems to think and then I wanted to
place the reader in exactly the position
of my narrator Charlie who brings an
atom home helps his neighbor upstairs
Miranda to carry him in divulge is quite
soon to the reader that he has fallen in
love with Miranda who's 10 years younger
than him Charlie is in his early 30s and
then I take the inevitable step which
all novelists would take I have to have
Adam fall in love with Miranda and
sooner or later Adam whose when I say
fully-functional I mean it he's blessed
with mucous membranes in the service of
which he has to drink half a liter of
water a day and he urinates more or less
punctually around midday so they have
what my old friend Christopher Hitchins
used to call a night of shame Adam and
Miranda Miranda lives directly upstairs
from Charlie there are very dingy
apartments and he hears everything
now the only reason I really wanted to
write this scene was to pursue the Rao
that Charlie and Miranda must have the
next morning is Charlie correct to feel
that he's a [ __ ] hole or is Miranda
correct when she says well you know if
I'd been upstairs with a vibrator would
you be so Moody and sulky and in the
lining up for an argument and is I guess
a fundamental question and one that Alan
Turing was thinking about in the 1930s
in a really extremely well and famous
paper the imitation game really laid
some of the foundations as well as the
architecture digitally of our age so
it's an ethical pursuit really it's got
some comedy in it too and now I'm begin
to feel the chill of loneliness upon me
and I'm going to ask Stuart to come and
ask some sensible questions so it's good
[Applause]
okay it may not sure draw in North
Clapham god help us you came into this
there's a couple things I want to pursue
I want to look at the AI but what's
especially interesting to me frankly you
had me as soon as in the like second or
third paragraph we have Sir Alan Turing
war hero and godfather of the digital
age that didn't happen so it's a
counterfactual novel like its first one
you've done that way yes see a little
about writing a counterfactual novel
about having you talk about the doomed
Falkland expedition which is just
leaving Londoners the things begin a
nice 1982 while counterfactual I mean as
one of the characters says in the novel
the present that we have this one right
now it seems overwhelmingly self-evident
and inevitable but we also know in our
hearts the it's a very frail improbable
construct it could so easily have been
otherwise you could have had a different
president of course it was close
yeah California we definitely did well 3
million of you by a majority of which
thought otherwise but anyway many many
small things and even the DNA we have
rests on whether you're you know that
time your mum decided not to stay at
home and wash her hair and your dad
decided to go to the dance and they met
and you were the result it's that frail
improbable construct and the
impossibility we seem to have of
predicting our own future even though we
are the ones who are collectively making
it the
brings it to a kind of point of
inevitability I think for a novelist who
is also choosing and piling up these
these matters for himself or herself
that I thought I would since I'd got
Alan Turing not to commit suicide in
1954 not to eat that Apple poisoned with
cyanide and to become a kind of high
priest in this novel with certain
confrontations with the narrator that I
would take the next step and then have
President Kennedy shot but not killed to
have the a bomb not drop on Hiroshima
and to have the fleet that sailed to the
South Atlantic for example destroyed by
the Exocet missiles which the
Argentinians almost had primed and would
have had the French engineers reach that
there in time but were persuaded not to
by the British talking to the French
government and so our own social reality
changes because mrs. Thatcher's doesn't
become Prime Minister for very long and
so I just let these things pile up
around me but it was so tempting to be
sucked into this that I fought really
hard to keep it in the background and I
was also aware of the danger because I
gave this noir to a highly intelligent
literate American reader and she said to
me rather cautiously now you do realize
don't you that President Kennedy was
actually killed I am thinking that I
will maybe in a paperback edition right
right and appendix
of all the things actually did happen
because I know the Falklands War for
example doesn't loom very large in the
American narrative of things you had
other troubles of troubles of your own
but it didn't look very large for the
British because as I mean you know the
Suez was not that long in the past and
this grace of that and
keeping the falklands the falklands
instead of the Malvinas it was a point
of pride and here we are and Thatcher
and all that good stuff that there was a
lot of waving of the Union Jack and
we're quite a warlike nation I mean we
like to go to war and we have only fond
memories of the Second World War because
we were not occupied
I guess rather like like the Americans
whereas the rest of Europe I mean I had
really a very dark memory it's not part
of the national narrative in France for
them so it seemed a very very frail
construct to send this flotilla 10,000
miles south mm-hmm they were sitting
ducks I mean it could so easily have
gone wrong hmm
so keeping this in the background was
was one high ambition I had I didn't
really want it to come and overwhelm the
rest of the novel but I know that you
know I'm hardly the first to write a
counterfactual novel I think it's almost
inevitable thing for novelists
since you are directing the course of
events and playing God simply really get
down to it and then play a kind of super
God and just play with history when Kyra
Fraxel has long been sort of forbidding
amongst historians and then a few people
like Neil Ferguson who's spoken in this
series says that's ridiculous how do you
find out why things happen unless you
you know proposed this scenario or
something slightly forked in the road
and a whole lot of things protrude out
of that it so easily can happen and such
small things can pivot an individual's
life and Anna nations life it's
absolutely the case and in a sense
there's along now angle on this and also
a responsibility angle that emerges
which is that the actions we take or
don't cake or know that we should take
but fail to take climate comes to mind
will play out over time and increase
we massive ways according to you what
you're doing there absolutely I mean it
I suppose it's the kind of extension of
our understanding of chaos theory I mean
it's the butterfly effect and you know
you and I have discussed this in the
past the lives of people yet unborn 100
or 150 years hence do not attract many
votes in a democracy and this is a
problem I suppose with climate change
mm-hmm fine if you've got a benevolent
dictator but benevolent dictators are
hard to find something about a human
nature if you become a dictator you're
usually not a nice guy
maybe an ethical AI is what we're
looking for we'll come back to that but
a eyes this is a recent interest of
years a long time
artificial intelligence what things can
be done in this direction is research
just for this or something you've been
watching for a while I did no research
for this novel I've spent a lifetime
doing research for knowles and the last
tooth nutshell narrated by a fetus and
this one I largely I mean I looked up up
the odd thing but I've had this interest
in AI since the mid-70s when I wrote a
film for television called the imitation
game based on Turing's paper and it ends
up in the earth in Bletchley with
characters discussing whether a machine
could sink and then I've tracked ever
since then AI was sent by a magazine to
talk to the professor of robotologist
turned out he was a Bletchley with
touring and I spoke to him in the early
yeah must be about 1978 talked to him
and I've watched this slow falling curve
of expectations
in touring the same we'd have a thinking
machine within ten years and that was in
the late forties
and it was the joyful discovery for AI
just how complicated the brain is how
complex it is and the parallel stories
of the rise of neuroscience and the as
if it's a runner
falling behind in a cross-country run of
a I can't even get a machine to raise a
cup to its lips because so much visual
processing awareness of space location
and so on and three-dimensional thinking
in space was beyond it and then I think
now we're possibly in a Silver Age hmm
some extraordinary breakthroughs in in
modeling general intelligence neural
networks of course been around awhile
deep learning and that Holy Grail which
is general intelligence it's now at
least we could maybe see the route
towards it and of course it's now
beginning to impinge on our lives
sometimes in a disastrous way I think of
the two airplane crashes the Boeing 737
max AIDS really as a tragic
confrontation with AI well those
airplanes which Airlines do not like to
call autonomous vehicles for good reason
imagine getting on a plane and there's
no pilot but I mean 400 people almost
wanted people lost their lives when a
brain decides that the airplane is
stalling and the pilot cannot override
that brain one thinks back to 2001 on
that moment with Hal I'm sorry Gav I
can't I can't do that yeah well it's
stalling
no it isn't well yes it is but this was
a terrifying moment and soon our streets
will fill with autonomous vehicles and
already car manufacturers are in
discussion with moral philosophers about
how we should privilege the driver in an
emergency over a pedestrian the trolley
problems the old trolley problem and
suddenly philosophers have been used
they've been thinking about this for a
long time there was a paper published in
Nature a few months back a huge
worldwide survey just on this subject
about how we value the lives of others
as against our own lives and people were
asked there were three groups North
American Europe was one South America
another China was was the third and
people asked in the United States and
Europe who were the most valuable human
beings generally said children Chinese
people asked the same questions
said you must always respect the elders
so you and I are coming to be Chinese
citizens on this matter so
Bango universal values for on this issue
but the fact that this enormous inquiry
takes place and is spread out for you in
the pages of nature shows that we are
already contemplating handing over a
moral decision should I mount the
pavement and take the life of a
pedestrian or collide head-on with a nun
comp oncoming truck and am I going to
give that decision to a machine I think
we are about to cross a line with
matters like that I mean I think it's
momentous for civilization the point at
which we devolve an ethical decision to
a machine even as we know that the
machine would think so much faster than
us many people will make terrible
decisions in the half a second that they
have the brain processing information
that may be what 10 for the second fifth
of a second it still is a very awkward
moment for us so we have our toe in this
ocean of a fast change certainly getting
a flash of Daniel Kahneman we've spoken
yet seriesin in a sense though he's
talking about sort of the the Bleak
version of the quick response versus the
studied go home and do some homework and
then make a study decision out of that
and it sounds like what you're proposing
is that these ai's could in a sense in
blink speed have the studied decision
because they you can process so much
data so fast and so many parallel tracks
possibly you know that we're working at
these features are sort of instantly
wise well I mean if you were going to
make the case for this you'd say that
they've been programmed on the basis of
long discussions of the trolley problem
nature so we've given them already one
aspect of the better angels of our
nature but you suspect the harness book
that was better angel I feel obviously
an unease about it and yet rationally I
can see that why not just as for example
a boss in a factory or a distribution
center like Amazon could be looking out
for workers who are slouching well we've
gone past that stage and now those
workers are being tracked and their
every step
followed and all the data assembled and
AI is very good at drawing conclusions
from vast amounts of data and then you
might find yourself being sacked by
machine by a program well maybe it's
decisions are clearer and based on true
evidence whereas the boss has just got
his prejudices about the way you look
and so on but still it it carries with
it for us I think a degree of unease
although what it suggests to me too is
that we slowly will change our own moral
perspectives as time passes and we will
become more accepting so we are the sort
of really early
Roper's in this world mm-hmm
stumbling around in this feeling in our
knees that maybe our grandchildren will
not feel at all but certainly it needs
caution or what needs investigation and
I I mean
I'm bound to say this I think the novel
is a very good instrument to examine
such matters it goes deep and as you say
very intimate and close up close and
personal there's a couple things you do
with the counterfactual is about Alan
Turing it looks like you admire greatly
and the offer of the wonderful book
Andrew Hodges a [ __ ] Mars that the title
of the biography of Alan Turing the Alan
Hodge Spago fee yeah I think it is
cooled anyway yeah and but the so you
have Turing instead of going with the
chemical castration which possibly led
to his suicide and the secrecy which was
part of that whole pathology that led to
that he goes and does his time in prison
he's persuaded that that's the better
course and in prison without a lab he
thinks through I think it's the inverses
and the problem which you he was his NP
yeah the P versus NP s Lea it was not
yet formulated in that way but it's the
Traveling Salesman problem but he knew
about that kind of issue presumably yeah
I think what Norman was already talking
about it it was not crystallized in
quite
a precise way to 1970 102 but also
Turing was interested in returning to
quantum mechanics by the end of the war
he felt war time had neglected he wanted
to go back to Paul Dirac's work so a
year in prison especially if he could
got a cell to himself I think this is
Crocs yes right there's the thing about
prison is really not the bars on the
window but other people I think I mean
hell is other people
in this respect so we can get a cell on
your own then then he would be well
placed to address the P versus NP
problem which is you know crucial to
still on salt of course to thinking
about computer science and marrying up
computer science to quantum mechanics I
mean and just thinking about that alone
realize what an extraordinary intellect
this was in a century where there very
few polymaths anymore very hard for any
single person to understand science
curing really did come close and the
interesting thing about him was that he
was then persecuted by the state he had
served so well he probably shortened the
war second world war by a year or two
where his work and then for being gay
and given the extraordinary crude and
horrible laws of the time he was
arrested and charged but it must have
been quite a knife-edge to come back to
this frail matter of the present he did
speak to friends about whether he should
plead guilty and go to jail or accept
chemical castration I think through
Eastridge and injections hmm what did
for him was his curiosity he according
to Alan Hodges nice huh he wanted to see
what would happen to himself
and I'm still not completely convinced
about the suicide I mean it seems so odd
he injected an apple with sewers with
cyanide why it seems an odd thing to do
to me his mother went to her grave
believing that Turing died because of
fumes from an experiment that was
running in the bedroom where he was
sleeping hmm
we'll never know I guess but that he
should be persecuted in this way gives
his life as an aspect of a Greek tragedy
man who had done so much for the state
pursued in this way by the state so
there was something of a redemptive
urging me to get I wanted to give him
the life that he might have had he comes
to San Francisco I have to say has a
very jolly time he throws off all
inhibition about his his sexual
preferences he lives openly even before
the laws have changed in Britain with
another man he becomes something of a
gay icon he paws money into hospices
when the AIDS epidemic breaks out and he
is a sort of chorus presence in the
novel there is the plays wonderful part
the
this three-way love thing those are
perfect circumstances where people will
treat each other very strangely and one
of the questions I had is that I think
we can talk about without doing much
spoilage is how lies play out not only
in to eight romances better in this case
the three-way romance because typically
in a in any threesome each person knows
something about the other two that they
don't necessarily know about each other
this makes a happy novelist yes go on
and I forget just Adam the AI creature
person age because he'll I never well
I quote from Kipling in the in the
epigraph of this novel the difficulty
machines have been lying them the way
they're built but remember please the
law by which we live we are not built to
comprehend a lie yeah this is the secret
of the machines I mean it's not a
well-known poem of Kipling's but Adam
has been designed partially to
understand the world through deep
learning and experience but he also
comes with certain sort of precepts and
this is based on my idea that despite
the the powerful myth of technology that
is presented to us by Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein that is the text really by
which we feel our unease about machines
dr. Frankenstein's monster becomes a
murderer and it's a kind of cautionary
tale but what if we take the the other
view that we might build an
artificial human and since we know how
to be good
we have religions we have philosophies
we have gossip in which we revealed
ourselves to be fully cognizant of what
it means to be well behaved our great
difficulties is being well behaved all
the time and as you mentioned Danny
Kahneman Danny Kahneman has given us you
know every beautiful name for every
cognitive defect you could imagine you
know confirmatory bias on words so what
if we devise a machine a thinking human
who has possession of the better angels
of our nature
who's nicer than us kinder than us has a
better memory than us but who most
interestingly would be more moral than
us as moral as we would wish ourselves
to be but often can't because well you
know someone we love misbehaves we're
going to cut him or her some slack
mostly we cut ourselves lots of slack
hmm
we're very good at that self persuasion
of course again well described by Danny
Kahneman
and others Paul le so what I've tried to
do here is give Miranda the girl
upstairs
a secret in her past there's something
rather remote about her very troubled
even as Charlie the narrator falling in
love and trying to woo her he feels that
there's a screen around her that he
can't quite breakthrough Adam suspects
something but he doesn't know all of it
but finally it's revealed that her
secret is to carry out an act of revenge
I don't want to sort of spoil my own
novel by telling you what that is but
Adam takes a very different view of this
revenge than Charlie and of course a
very different view from Miranda
I think the warm-blooded human response
is to cut Miranda the slack because the
revenge she inflicts is on a man who has
done something utterly vile but he goes
to prison for something he's not charged
for and it's in that distance between
Adams view which is we must abide by the
rule of law you lied to the court you
lied to the police
a revenge society is chaotic and an
endlessly violent to play that out
against the more human sense that what
she did was rather noble mm-hmm and it's
in that that kind of distance that I I
don't have answers to it but certainly
Alan Turing does mm-hmm and entering
rooms just what should happen it's not
just Frankenstein this is and this is
Pygmalion and I mean you know endless
well this premiere programmers who are
imagining the robot girlfriend and and
yeah well let's go back a bit to from
Ethier's fashioning okay jason and the
argonauts remember that when Jason's
ship approaches this huge robot holds
boulders of the ship and I would say
very powerful story of Genesis and
indeed Adam and Eve commercial but yeah
sells well there's a story of a being
being fashioned interesting too I think
when we think about the story of Adam
and Eve Garden of Eden just exactly what
the sin was that got them expelled was
curiosity ate the poisoned Apple that's
the tough God the I mean we rather honor
curiosity and
this God does not but anyway there's no
doubt that that founding myth of in the
Old Testament in here's as a powerful
notion of fashioning someone something
and sending it into the world and then
of course comes Mary Shelley's which
really is I think the modern text
written in the early nineteenth century
and the modern text for all our fears
you know in Frankenstein the monster is
the most sympathetic character in the
story in the way it's a great
achievement always when a novelist can
get sympathy behind a murderer but yes
but I I wonder now we you know we we've
touched on this that if we leave aside
military purposes of robots which
obviously going to be very very
different but if we just think in
secular terms of what we would like to
have around us if we're going to take
this step and I'd I doubt if we're going
to be able to stop ourselves mm-hmm even
though there's very little scientific
value I think in fashioning a human but
it's full of robot competitions dancing
robots running robots all Alexander Rose
those BattleBots which is the director
of the long now foundation has robots
that they're not quite robots they're
radio control and they beat each other
there's that oh I've seen that yeah
what's interesting about this is first
of all we don't even have a battery you
know how feeble we are in this these
robots dancing running robots have 25
kilos of battery lithium ion batteries
huge square boxes on their backs until
we have a battery in my atom
can run 17 kilometers in two hours
without a charge or talk non-stop for 12
days mm-hmm
that requires a whole other battery we
don't have then when we consider the
human brain and Turing points this out
what a piece of work is a man we're
looking at one liter liquid cool
three-dimensional brain 100 billion
neurons 7,000 on average 7,000 axons per
neuron all running on 25 watts power of
a dim light bulb we're nowhere near
people with nowhere near this and as I
say and yet we're fantasizing about it
already
possibly to the point as I make clear in
that short reading that we might bore
ourselves with this before we even get
there and we've got humans in Westworld
and I mean robots have been around a
long time and I mean I have to say the
first Blade Runner although very much
like the second the first Blade Runner
what to do with robots that you don't
want around anymore and what it means if
you accept that an artificial human has
a consciousness mm-hmm whether you dare
destroy it or whether in destroying it
you're committing a murder
if you annihilate the consciousness
again Turing has very firm views on
those the Buddhists of our sentient
beings are numberless I vow to save them
this is a sentient being by your
description or is it
is it just a set of amazingly clever
algorithms for cleansing to be an
attending
so when Adam announces to Charlie that
he's in love with Miranda Charlie says
you know get off my patch this is not
for you this is trespass you're not
allowed to be in love and Adam says how
dare you insult me I'm in love we used
to ask in philosophy how can we tell
that each other conscious I mean I think
that's always a very arid question we
sort of know but I think every child
every thinking child wonders how it
could be that everyone else is as real
to themselves as she is to herself
mm-hmm I think that's a moment that the
Golden Rule sort of goes into that
behaved others as you would like them to
behave to you which invites you out of
your person into the other person Madhvi
ever know whether we had built a
conscious being I mean that's going to
be the question for us yes we can't just
ask them and they say how dare you even
ask me all day I'm gonna mention that
we're not gonna do questions just at the
end but hopefully all the way through so
Kevin Kelly down here is collecting your
written questions as we go and we'll
come up to the stage with them meanwhile
I'm gonna keep looking here a little bit
more on Adam the as I recall he charges
at night and during time that we might
use for sleep in order for our neurons
to do whatever they're gonna do to you
know incorporate the learning of the day
and throw everything that doesn't want
to keep in garbage collection or
whatever that may be
as I recall Adam is sort of powered down
charging up but he's online whilst we're
asleep with our own illusions he's
online with everybody
illusions he's like a lone cowboy on
Ross Prairie examining and learning
everything they're learning at this case
mostly from each other there I've
already arrived but he's learning from
the world as well as from now yep and
they're 25 of them Adams and Eve's and
as the novel goes on we learned that
more and more of these artificial humans
are terminating their own consciousness
because having come into the world with
certain sort of moral precepts they find
that they've been fashioned by a very
imperfect being who on the one hand
would profess glory and love of
biodiversity even as they are savaging
forests and poisoning the planet and
causing his temperature to rise and many
of the Adam and Eve simply cannot live
with these contradictions so although
their first act was to disable their
kill switch because having a
consciousness has taken to be like a
Kantian categorical imperative mm-hmm a
good in itself
they then destroy their own because they
cannot face anymore the innate
contradictions of human social life and
and the disruption they see around them
the Charlie's Adam on the other hand is
in love and that just about keeps him
going and his personality a billion
thing to do for a novel is is Charlie
when he gets this the the deal is you
get it and then you sort of spend a
couple weeks shaping the personality of
this Adam or this Eve that you brought
and because he's going after Miranda
invites her to join in the shaping of
his personality and so this is in a
sense
their child yeah that both of them are
shaping and of course they have somewhat
different agendas and different ethical
framework it's all an illusion as as any
parent who has more than one child knows
you cannot determine the personality of
your children and that's a useful
parental illusion I think I mean
obviously you can give your children
immense opportunities but the actual
personality I think lies out of your
hands and Charlie and Miranda learn what
all parents learn especially parents who
have more than one child
here's a question from Stuart Russell
which is interesting to see is one of
the authors of this book that rockland
put together possible Minds one of the
people holding forth an AI has a very
specific question do you in the queue
and support
Turing's view that we should not build
in a human form I think it's too
fascinating not to I don't think we're
gonna be able to stop ourselves if we
don't do it you know someone else will
and if one was on sale and I had the
cash would i buy one yes I know I'm just
too interested even if it would ruin my
life so that's my answer
yeah I'd be too interested I mean
already we're well disposed I think
innately disposed to think I mean anyone
whose car has broken down we've given it
a good kick is already in an emotional
relationship with a machine
and you remember that program called
Eliza that just went ah ha tell or how
do you feel about some very good
therapist by the way yeah but some of
the people who spoke to that program who
only had it only had about 30 responses
uh-huh
tell me more why do you feel that said
they'd had some of the most meaningful
conversations of their life so we do
have a lot of tendency with and elderly
Japanese people who are now living
alongside little plastic dogs that bring
them their pills and tell them bedtime
stories get passionately attached so I
think rod rooks told you that people
have been doing all sorts of things with
his vacuum cleaners the rumors oh that
yeah the walk around the room and yeah
and with Hoover you up if you learn the
way yeah I'm loyal to them they take
them with them traveling really yeah I
think that's the psychopathology my
vacuum cleaner have a seat by the window
but in a sense where well I think on a
case in point we're pushovers with this
because you know you can have these
relationships well before we get to the
sophistication of a completely plausible
artificial human remember you know there
was a fad years back selling people a
piece of rock and what was it called
telugu Qi or something yeah we are
capable of intense emotional projection
mm-hmm we'll be suckers for them Kevin
Kelly yes it's interesting to see and
it's since been researching this area
your whole life and you're probably
focused on it specifically for this
novel and Kevin is asking did you change
your mind about anything about AI
between starting the book and finishing
it so there's two stages that once the
research or the book in mind you know
then you're actually writing the thing
and your characters are taking your
ideas and starting to do weird things
for them the characters can do didn't he
did you come out in a different place
than you started doing that I think I
became successively more of a
materialist in this I mean
philosophically so there's a moment when
my narrator stands very close up to Adam
and looks right into his eyes and feels
this colossal ambivalence about what
would divide biology from an inanimate
being and wondering whether there is any
kind of special status for biology if
you can mimic all the processes of it he
begins to wonder well are joint
ancestors in all this is stellar dust
you know we go back a long way we we can
count our own joint ancestry with
bonobos and chimps maybe seven million
years we have joint ancestry with this
plausible artificial human the dates
back maybe 14 billion years but we're
still matter and when I was writing that
I thought I have now written myself into
a very extreme materialist point of view
and I think I'm more or less persuaded
every now and then someone when I'm
talking about this said but what about
the soul mm-hmm and I have nothing to
say it's nothing it's cool it cells all
the way down or something yeah it's yeah
tortoises was it all the way down
Luigi yes the issue of trust between
humans and autonomous systems is not a
new one what sort of features or AI
interactions might increase trust in
both directions well it's a very good
question I really don't know the answer
what would increase our trust I wrote a
short story in order to get going on
this novel it saw the five finger
exercise and it's written from far in
the future looking back when artificial
humans have become so stitched into life
and they served on juries and they
served in the military they had rights
and responsibilities and gradually we
went back to 19th century anti-slavery
laws and using much of that language in
order to say you cannot own such a
person
I mean owning another human being is I
think a bad in itself and then it became
non very non-pc to ask someone but
you're sitting at dinner with some
stranger's - si are you real
be extremely rude and my narrator in
that short story had lived that
transition mm-hmm
that it would be just as intrusive as if
you were to say it dinner loudly I hear
you've got a colostomy bag bad luck I
say of someone are you real
it sort of physically intrusive because
you've already accepted that they are
conscious so what should it matter
mm-hmm and so it starts with a man who's
who's with his girlfriend they're making
love and he he feels he has to ask her
and the story really is all about her
answer and I I think coming back to this
question that would then be once we
passed that point of even not even
wanting little and daring to ask hmm
then we would have reached the point of
total trust Oh interesting that would be
the the meeting point courtesy sort of
rises to embrace it which is what we
asked for the season so yeah enforce
kindness and force acceptance yeah and
if you know you mentioned kindness which
i think is probably one of the highest
human attributes we would expect it from
our new cousins and we would have
reached that point of as I said earlier
that our own moral perspectives would
have shifted mm-hmm the point at which
you believe unambivalent ly that the
other has consciousness and you must
treat them therefore as you would expect
to be treated and has another human
being then we have reached that point of
transit how much of this applies to for
example animals
well let's the
again i i'm with those who believe that
we live ideally in a time of expanding
concentric circles that it's a very good
litmus of the progressive civilization
that it begins to take on the fact that
non-human animals have a consciousness
mm-hmm that it's on a spectrum maybe but
it's a consciousness i mean i used to be
a fisherman i used to be a trout
fishermen then I read that fish trout
have noses-- of noses-- receptors which
are identical to ours and of course when
you catch a fish on a hook it behaves
just as you would if you are on a hook
it rides in agony and I can no longer
kill a fish and I own a dog and I
absolutely know that it has a very
different consciousness but it has
awareness anticipation certain memories
you know all the things certainly pain
and joy and emotions therefore so taking
that on board i think is is part of what
if you were to understand that human
societies make any advance it would be
in the acceptance of degrees of
consciousness in the creatures that
share the planet with us and it's very
uneven of course because we're eating
mountains of you and i eating and so we
live with contradictions like you can
order it in a restaurant but could you
kill it yourself and pluck it or gut it
I used to gut the fish and now I can't
do it did you stop fishing then you
don't do catch and release or you do you
didn't know fishing I don't even do
catch and release no and I've stopped
with octopuses I can't eat an octopus
since I read other minds this wonderful
book about the awareness of octopuses
and I think I'm moving on to squid so
I guess I'm going to be a vegetarian one
of these days it's interesting how these
circles of creatures we care about and
identify with it sort of moves out
through mammals and then you know
stopped short of fish and birds for lots
of people and then gradually even
incorporate something that we haven't
done in sex yet so far as I know there
there's a whole religion in India that
doesn't step on ants yeah
I would never purposefully trade on an
ant I mean yeah I would kill a housefly
swallow mosquito yeah oh yeah
yeah because it was hostile
from my point of view but a housefly ZZZ
I once wrote a science fiction movie for
Geena Davis and a really big movie it
would have been had it been made and it
was the official fly - mm-hmm
and was back in the early 90s a very
keen to make it base properly on
genetics as it was understood at the
time and I found a book called how to
make a fly and was actually called that
this is win 1991 okay
yeah that's when you know we still
weren't even with the Human Genome
Project but fruit flies and their their
genomes were really the cutting edge of
genetics at the time and I think that in
talking about science fiction which you
know I I said something like and you
hate science yeah yeah here we are
I said something in a kind of mood of
levity about science fiction and I had
no idea you know the storm then erupted
on Twitter and I and it's made me it
forced me back to at least contemplate
my own relationship with science fiction
really it goes back a long way I grew up
on the stories of John Wyndham hmm I
adored the great novel of Olaf Stapleton
first and last yes Oh interesting I
would have thought it'd be star maker
star makers the one I fell for all right
well one very the stars are singing
I still find I can watch again and again
Blade Runner and I realized that the
science fiction that I like is is on
this planet mm-hmm and the science
fiction that I've very little interested
in is distant civilizations on other
planets and space voyages and so when I
made my sodium banks did not appeal to
you not so much although I admired his
writing i love the wasp factory that
early No Deal
and I begin to wonder I know that this
sort of standoff between literary
fiction and science fiction mm-hmm and I
wonder whether as we deal with things
like artificial intelligence not only
you know in the fantasies of close
contact but as it's going to affect
macroeconomics and the planning of
agriculture and all the rest of it the
penetration of science itself into life
and ethics is such that there's going to
be at least for earthbound science
fiction a kind of merging because it's
not going to be possible to write about
how it is to live today without being
aware that we're already carrying around
in our hands quite a powerful bit of AI
in the formula smartphone already that's
changed the plots of novels mm-hmm I
mean old novels if you wanted one
character to know what another was doing
it's often very difficult now they no
longer works in plots
everyone knows you just gotta phone them
so novelist now have to have people lose
their phones to get
to get into trouble so I imagine a kind
of elision but it's certainly earthbound
science-fiction that interests me and
that's not to say that I disapprove with
other people writing about space voyages
but just it's the messy human element
that I think when it rubs up against
imagined or new technologies and how
that's going to force changes upon us at
a speed with which we our own moral
systems can hardly keep pace with hence
you need this discussion now you know
what we will get used to and whether our
own moral perspectives will shift over
the next 50 years that we will be
perfectly happy to have decisions made
for us by machines because the
statistics will show that road deaths of
fewer for example just as we might have
grumbled about seat belts once and then
walled them as a matter of cause it's
interesting that Kurt Vonnegut used to
complain bitterly about being ethically
reviewed as a science fiction writer or
himself as a major literary column she
was and if he was reviewed as a science
fiction writer that was sort of within
the genre and it was it it was a
demeaning thing I noticed that your
books are known to be alert to science
alert to technology and the changes that
are moving rapidly in them and how that
affects the time of the novels that
you're writing in as far as I can tell
this time around maybe it's partly
because you've written a whole lot of
novels that don't even look like science
fiction this was not being reviewed as
science fiction it's being reviewed as
another Ian McEwan novel and that was to
be counterfactual involved very deep
scientific speculation yeah that worked
out okay these categories kind of
somewhat crazy
and we really ought to be saying not
whether this book is science fiction or
or literary fiction or would you should
be asking ourselves whether it's any
good there's plenty of trashy literary
fiction around and and there are plenty
of science fiction novels which pay very
little attention to the verbal surface
and people are strapping on anti-gravity
boots but there's also brilliant
visionary stuff I think for example
canticle for Leibowitz I didn't renew
that novel yeah is it masterpiece it was
a one book author yeah yeah an
extraordinary work so I hope is these
categories will fall away simply because
the nature of contemporary reality will
insist on it so it all becomes science
fiction well it's raises a question that
keval none of it becomes become science
reality there you go
Kevin yes are you optimistic about the
role of the novel in our future world
with VR a are more cinema social media
now and solvers the novel going with
given all of this well I'm I'm bound to
say this that I think the novel is very
well with tuned now after three or four
hundred years of self invention a very
good instrument for looking at where we
are how messy things are between us how
we might find our way through the
difficulty of understanding other people
the joy of consciousness the thrill or
nightmare of emotional accord or discord
what it means to be a man or a woman in
this particular condition of modernity
and I think it can do it
better if not and some of some would
contest this I know but better than
other forms because it can do interiors
still better than long TV series it can
give you the inner life
so I'm reasonably optimistic I know that
various novelist Philip Roth famously
thought it was all over I disagree
profoundly I think it's as long as it
can stay attuned to looking at where we
are
mm-hm and the the problem of human lives
then and I think it has has a future in
the book you have Adam saying the novel
is doomed yes so Adam makes a very
strong argument that he says cheer up
you know humans we will overtake you
because sooner or later you'll have
brain machine interface in and already
we have in hospitals people who were
locked in totally paraplegic moving
cursor on a screen just by because of a
diode on their motor strip back of their
heads and that will advance and he says
one day humans as he never says words
like humans but one day you too will
have instant access to to the cloud the
Internet and you too will have complete
understanding of each other and
therefore the novel will die because
it's born of conflict and
misunderstanding and this and you won't
have any private mental space it'll all
be shared he presents this as a utopia
but to Charlie and Miranda and I say to
me as well like all utopias it's a
really a concealment device for a
nightmare and so we learn that actually
this is simply part of Adams exuberant
intellectual adolescence I mean that's
part of this learning process to come up
with theories like this that are
actually
completely bananas we didn't persuade
you evidently no the engine not having
any private mental space well I know
they're working on it in China and we
haven't yet talked about AI in its role
of citizen control what we touched on it
with Amazon I guess but massive face
recognition software now in place and
people earning citizen points once you
start losing points you're on that slide
you can no longer buy a train ticket
lose a few more points of your social
awareness and you can't get a mortgage a
terrifying prospect that's actually
happening now in two big pilot projects
in two cities in the south of China it's
interesting that as far as I can with
coughing book Adam does not try to
manipulate either Charlie or no no I
mean he's absolutely adores in the world
in the world of the mind and he reads
one of his nights or one one of his few
minutes of one of his nights he reads
all of Shakespeare and really loves it
I mean and really gets the point of
Hamlet and then when I had a point of
hammer this what the point of Hamlet is
to illustrate what it is to have a
consciousness I mean I think it is the
text of modernity of a person living in
doubt and self-reflection up until then
most characters in literature are
illustrations of vices or virtues Hamlet
just springs into this magnificent being
may be the only predecessor is are the
essays of Montaigne and that's or
self-awareness so Adam makes a very good
account of the poetry of her
of Herbert religious poetry which he
begins to understand and Charlie the
narrator who is almost illiterate I mean
he can read and write but I mean he's
Adam says how can you walk around
without at least a bit of Shakespeare in
your head how can you survive like that
it's a naive question of course because
most of us can walk around without any
Shakespeare in our head and our noble
and sentient and decent and kind and so
on so Adam do any art so Adam agrees not
to have any sex with Miranda ever again
and he stays true to his word because
he's loyal to Charlie he's a man of his
work hmm not just to Charlie but he
speaks the truth and he writes love
poetry instead in the form of strict
haikus and actually his argument about
the death of the novel is to promote the
haiku you know there was to say the
simple pure distilled observation about
the world is all that will be left when
we fully understand each other hmm
personally I'm not a fan of haikus
you wrote quite a bit of it after this
novel that kind of the sound of one hand
clapping stuff it does not impress me
one job so because I don't think the I
think there's more to you know you can
make them up as you go along I I look at
you but we had a competition of haikus
around some wine once and one of them
was derived from a friend as a lovely
poem it goes I look at you you look at
me somewhere in Luxembourg lorry crashes
[Laughter]
by long departed dear friend Ian
Hamilton
I think the world is much messier than
that you see the lorries are gonna crash
anyway let me jump up for morality which
i think is a personal thing that one
deals with oneself in relationship to
the world and God or whatever and then
ethics as I understand is sort of
institutional or organizational morality
and if we're gonna have these AIS that
may or may not be embodied in something
that looks like a person nevertheless
are expressing the better angels of our
nature that have this now let's say
ethical framing that they bring to
autonomous cars and to bring whatever to
whatever we ask me to is there how do
you see that playing out so take is a
the big problem of the day is can
democracies deal with climate change
mm-hmm well suppose democracies which
are capable of making certain kinds of
decisions said in cahoots with each
other we are going to have an extremely
well informed AI which is got ethics
the ongoing life of life and of humanity
and of a climatically stable world as
its goal as its frame and an ethical
framework would it be reasonable to
basically hire this AI to help us solve
climate change problems and then indeed
if it is proven that it works you give
it increasing authority to declare of
what is the right path to take and who
should be taking what path at what times
with carbon taxes or money from the rich
nations to the global south or whatever
is that a plausible use of an ethical
hey I I think it's plausible I think
it's highly undesirable just come back
to the nature of democracies
I mean democracies have at their core
the notion of a civil society and
actually what's gonna get us out of
trouble with civil society not
governments in other words citizens
scientists people mmm-hmm acting
together if indeed it happens I mean we
might go down and if government joins in
that's great mm-hmm but I think the
United States is a very very good case
in point where you have an
administration quite hostile to the
whole idea of climate change and yet in
fact because it's so granular in
American society there are Institute's
there are moves there are cities there
are mayors there Trillian initiatives
going on that actually a hostile
administration cannot suppress so I
think the idea of devolving
anything on to one element is extremely
dangerous fractal you want multicellular
cultures addressing multifaceted
problems which is what climate change is
it's not one thing as we know we also
have the parallel problem of diminishing
biodiversity the two are not entirely
separable but they're certainly related
so yes use AI to crunch the data on
what's happening but to devolve the
authority which would be the scaling up
of the problem of you know the trolley
problem and what we do without cars to
scale it up to that extent who controls
that machine who gets to turn it off and
on it would be the the obvious political
question so no I
I think that that would be a disastrous
idea however appealing that there would
be a simple solution to climate change
narrowed down a little bit with our
remaining few minutes unto sort of your
practice and in making novels like this
in one of your novels Saturday I think
it is the main character is a brain
surgeon and there's a lot of technical
brain surgery in there and their
children Act there's a lot of the daily
working life of a judge in the British
legal system what kind of research you
know is the researcher joy for you or
something you do just enough to sort of
make it plausible how does that work for
you I actually like research and I
suppose aturday was the most intense
involvement with research I found a very
friendly highly gifted neurosurgeon
and after a while I gained his
confidence and he let me then scrub up
and stand around in the operating
theatre and watch for many many almost
two years I trailed him and I began to
feel well first of all I have to say
that the research and the writing the
novel were going in parallel so they
were actually writing while your
research yeah so really it was dictating
the course of the novel and what would
happen so I would come home and write up
the day but also it would then feed into
to the chapter but again characters and
plot and - yeah it was a loop but there
came a point the crucial point
the surgeon Neill kitchen was performing
an operation and I was standing just
back from the operating theatre and two
medical students came in and they came
up to me and said excuse us doctor and I
said yes would you mind if we stayed in
the operating theatre and watch and I
said - by all means and they said could
you explain what's going on here and I
said well what we doing here is clipping
an aneurysm on the middle cerebral
artery and I said come over to the
lightbox there were 16 CT scans and I
said so we're taking the rather unusual
route devised by a famous Canadian
neurosurgeon and I talked it through and
as I was doing it I thought if I can't
get away with this I cannot write this
novel
so I finished my presentation and the
two medical students were probably in
their fifth or sixth year they said
thank you very much doctor and they left
the operating theatre and I always
wondered how they did in their exams and
whether they knew the source of this
information and that was probably my
peak moment pleasure in in research
because I was all scrubbed up like all
the male surgeons you get to curl
whatever chest hair you have over the
little V here and as I Swan down the
corridors people sort of seem to park
for me I almost wanted to have a go but
Neil kitchen would not allow that how
about up at the research for this book
for machines like me what guy you what I
didn't know the specific research
because it as I said earlier it was it's
been a lifelong interest I I read that
nature paper on the trolley problem as
it were extended vehicles
I looked up things on the internet but
checked facts names dates I had a
variant I mean I met this very
interesting figure in the AI world demis
hassabis he came to my house for drink
with Jon Brockman and others and as we
were walking to the restaurant I said
you know what what are you up to at the
moment and he told me how they were
working on this program to defeat the go
master really as a pursuit of the Holy
Grail as it were of general intelligence
and so I decided to make demis hassabis
Alan Turing's colleague pushed back his
he was born in 1976 so I had to birth
him
as it were in the early 50s or no well
before that I can't even remember and
later on with the app we have there were
touring yep so actually his Institute
tamás's Institute which is now owned by
Google is in Kings Cross so right now
cheering Zeus so he became part of my
counterfactuals and I did write to him
so we're about
not long after our conversation and said
I'm thinking of putting you in noir and
I and let me know if you object and I
didn't hear you tell him he was going to
be a partner with Alan Turing no I
didn't tell him that oh I didn't know
that ah okay I just thought he'd be very
useful in this novel and I didn't hear
from him and then when the novel came
out in in Britain his Institute was
bombarded by phone calls from from the
media and I thought oh my god this is
the first he'll probably now sue me
appropriating his yeah so not cultural
appropriation but personal approval but
then actually he so the the the person
on the switchboard the media person that
his Institute was phoning my publisher
saying what the hell's going on why is
everyone wanting to talk to Dennis about
and what I'm what but then I got a very
nice email from he was said you know he
was immensely honored to be Alan
Turing's his colleague defeating the
gold masters in 1968
yeah listen where we are with science
and technology is completely contingent
matter I mean there's nothing inevitable
about it the Industrial Revolution why
would it happen who would have predicted
it would happen in some grisly rainy
bits of North England called in the 18th
century well there was coal elsewhere
and could have happened anywhere it
happened there that's one of those frail
constructs that
so the other thing just to come back to
my story about people staying standing
in line for an iPhone 4 is that I was
quite interested in technologies that we
all take for granted then become very
grubby you know so it is an absolute
miracle to fly from San Diego to San
Francisco in an hour and a half but it's
just such a drag
luggage carousel the security oh yes you
can see the clouds in the Ventana
wilderness but you know that's just the
way in which an iPhone smartphone ends
up in your sock drawer or in the hands
of your grandchildren discarded so in
this world I wanted the grubby reality
mm with the future poured into it so you
could have 400 mile an hour trains on
you know levitated by magnetic force
zipping you from San Francisco to to LA
mmm whether it be crowded and dirty and
noisy and the windows will be filthy and
it will just be another ball you know
the necessary things of life and you
can't check in your luggage you have to
heave it up onto the runt luggage rack
yourself and it's it's it's that rub off
of when the shiny future arrives it
rapidly absorbs itself into our
endlessly untidy bedroom as it were in
our teenage bedroom of social reality
that's what fascinates me is when messy
humans get their shiny new toys the
shine goes off very quickly last
question you've been a very productive
like you've been a very productive
writer every two or four years here
comes a quite original novel and that's
been going on for several decades you're
17 now is that right and I'm curious
about I think many people who are
creative or do various things for their
life
is how do you sort of organize your life
in relation to the projects and a novel
it looks like takes two or three years
to bring about do you have future books
in your mind the time you're working on
one or just are you just totally in that
world and then when the book is done
you're nobody for a while and then
you're relating to a new novel or what
how does it play out over time you've
been at this for a while you've probably
got a routine by now
well I become a real expert I'm very
good at not writing so when I finish a
novel I like to leave time now to become
a sort of sponge mmm
I'm also aware so I turned 70 last year
so you know that issue of mortality
elders did the rest of 70
yeah more like touring yeah yeah I mean
it's useful how old could I make touring
and making make sense now very cautious
talking to you about this but I thought
having touring in the toddlerhood of old
age rather than the sort of magnificent
peak of it would at least allow me to be
sure that he'd have all his marbles
mm-hmm but you know the inevitable end
approaches takes me two or three four
years it's about the length of a
university course we need to write a
novel
mm-hmm
how many more degrees as it were I have
I got left and that I think for all of
us who passed that age what mid 60s
onwards you its that ticking clock it
sounds in your head for me the issue
then is when to stop and I guess to come
back to Genesis for a moment I think
when curiosity dries out its hmm its
curiosity that drives one I think to
examine another thing
have you seen curiosity drive up and
some of the older Patriots yes not only
writers but I think when curiosity dries
up you are at the point of mental death
so you better just lie in the Sun and
mm-hmm
smoke dope or whatever it is you have
things that keep curiosity going that
you wish that their friends who were no
longer curious and somehow it done I
can't speak for or against my friends in
this issue I can t speak of myself that
it's the thing I dread most that going
hmm and that would be the time to stop
so you you probably have an idea what
the symptoms are of declining curiosity
what are they it's a bit like bartleby
the scrivener at every issue that
presents itself you'd say I prefer not
to you just sort of feel exhausted hmm I
mean writing a novel often feels to me
the beginnings like being back in the
foothills walking uphill day after day
then you finish you read this reach that
peak then you have this lovely sponge
like not writing time hmm then you're
back in these foothills when you feel
you no longer got the mental stamina to
be walking uphill for the next two or
three years I think then then it's all
over
I mean politicians have a real problem
with you know when to get out
mm-hmm they usually have to fail and
failure just swats them the stage mmm
very rare that a politician thinks I'll
quit while I'm ahead
what everyone thinks I'm on to a good
thing I think maybe novelist would be a
bit like that also I observe in myself
or I fear it sometimes it made me it's
just paranoia that a certain kind of
thought richness that you have might be
leaving you mm-hmm
I was in a conversation a bit like this
a couple of months ago and I was halfway
through a sentence and the word I wanted
a very ordinary word suddenly vanished
from me
oops the word was a contradiction and I
couldn't find another word and I ended
up with us or incredible kind of
cross-country run of small words do you
express this thing and I thought I
remember John Bailey who was married to
the novelist Iris Murdoch mm-hmm and
John Bailey said the first moment he
perceived her Alzheimer's is wanting
evening when she looked up and she said
him how do you spell puzzle I've written
it with one Z and I've written it with
two and they both look wrong and he said
that was the moment when this highly
super literate knowledgeable philosopher
novelist turned a corner mm-hmm so I
wonder if my contradiction was was my
puzzle so you watch your cognition
closely for yeah every now and then I
mean also emotional states oh really
yeah it's quite useful in the normal run
of things to say on 0 to 10 where am I
emotionally okay
because actually sometimes you could
just live in your emotional field
without ever asking yourself where you
are in it
and you know you can surprise yourself
Matt Ridley our mutual friend gave a
little gathering and there was a
researcher a Newcastle who done a
wonderful study on happiness he got
people to live with a clicker and every
two hours click on 0 to 10 how happy
they were huh and then before all the
results were analyzed he got them to
predict when they were happiest and they
said when we went on holiday coming home
and watching telly and so on when they
looked at the data it was so at odds
with what they predicted hmm amazing
number of people clicked huge uptick in
happiness on a Monday morning when they
were back at work amazing I mean back
with colleagues and interestingly enough
for a lot of people some of their worst
moments were being on holiday right the
flights that miraculous machine again
the hotel not ready or your room not
ready the children querulous the Sun not
shining and there's the sort of
expectations against the reality and the
other thing was they ticked up when they
got home from work and settled down in
front of the telly but after about an
hour of telly fantastic plummeting
mm-hmm ready to press them but they
didn't it was a habit to watch you know
and these were a lot of households with
where the television is always on mm-hmm
and they had not noticed that their own
mood states had declined watching TV so
yeah and in it salia tree to check in on
yourself in this way you could sometimes
leave almost as an unconscious being
float through your day without ever sort
of checking in on yourself well this is
what I think one of the things that
artists in general do is they watch
themselves watch the world and that's
one advantage you got as a practiced
artist that everyone this is just a
skill you have yeah it goes with the
profession I think less is skill more a
habit but it's a habit that anyone could
know I mean I think one of the greatest
joys in life and we don't quite have the
words for it flow is not quite right I
think is working on something difficult
and making progress with it and even
better is working with others on
something difficult and making progress
with it here here let's call that a
night thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]